when you get started with web
development they say you gotta learn the
css fundamentals i agree but when you
get out into the real world you'll find
that one does not just use plain css to
build an app
the left side's getting lower than the
right side i can see what's happening
now twist it all right
it's just too painful there are
literally hundreds of libraries that
attempt to make css better but so far
there's no universal solution today
we'll take a look at seven different
ways to write css specifically in a
react app using next.js but most
importantly we'll look at the trade-offs
of each approach so you can decide
what's best for your project if you're
new here like and subscribe and check
out my full courses on fireship io to
learn even more by building complete
projects now let's talk about css here i
have a pristine next.js app and the most
primitive way to style it is to create
global css that applies to the entire
application that might work okay for a
small application but it doesn't scale
well at all the first problem you'll run
into is that naming things gets really
hard because css cascades to address
this you'll likely need to use a naming
convention like bem but it's not going
to be very fun it's hard to do perfectly
and you'll probably end up using
important everywhere because you've got
more important things to do than figure
out how to not use important the other
problem is that it generally results in
a very large and inefficient css bundle
the larger the bundle size the slower
the app loads luckily next.js supports a
tool called css modules out of the box
to address some of these concerns a css
module file looks just like regular css
but it can be scoped to an individual
component and that means you don't have
to worry about name collisions when
writing your code in other words you can
have two different module files that
define the same class name but because
they're scoped locally you don't have to
worry about them interfering with each
other in addition it tells next.js
exactly which css to load for a given
page which can reduce the bundle size
now that may sound inefficient because
you may want to share styles between
multiple components but modules have a
special composes property that can
import and override code from a
different module overall modules will
make your life much easier but we're
still dealing with plain css here and
one thing it lacks is programmatic
features like loops functions mixins and
things like that the classic way to make
css better is to use a preprocessor
which allows you to write a different
syntax like sas less or stylus than use
a compiler to convert that code back
into plain css the most popular version
is scss which is a superset of plain css
allowing you to write regular css with
additional features on top of it in
next.js all you have to do is install
the sas compiler then change the file
names in your project all the
compilation will happen in the
background for you automatically and now
you can use features like variables
mixins and functions to make your code
way more concise and efficient sas is
great and all but the problem is that
it's an entirely different language to
learn and it's completely decoupled from
our main application code we already
have our javascript and html together
why not add our css there as well and
that's where your css and js libraries
come in there are many different
libraries out there like styled
components emotion jss styletron and
many others but the characteristic they
all share is they allow you to write css
in your javascript code that allows you
to do many of the programmatic things
you can do in sas but you have the full
power of javascript at your fingertips
but more importantly it makes it easy to
create dynamic styles based on the state
of your application in next.js there's a
homegrown solution called style.jsx to
use it all you have to do is open up a
style tag and a component use the jsx
attribute then write your css as a
template literal string the cool thing
about this is that you can now compute
or interpolate values directly inside
the style which means you can
dynamically change the styles based on
state changes to the application in
addition these styles are scoped to the
location where they're defined which
means that like modules they won't bleed
out to affect other styles that's pretty
cool but we still have one major problem
we need to figure out how to write code
that will make the application actually
look good one way to address that is to
bring in a utility class library like
tailwind or windy css to provide a huge
collection of utility classes that can
help us rapidly build out a good looking
ui tailwind is very powerful but it does
require some additional tooling and
configuration to get started once
installed you'll be able to style your
components with utility classes instead
of writing the css directly in my
experience this tends to be a much
faster way to implement the design
you're going for because all your styles
are right at your fingertips with ide
intellisense in addition it can purge
all of your unused css automatically to
result in a very efficient bundle size
but not everybody likes the utility
class approach because your component
html code can get out of control very
quickly it is a big commitment and
you'll have to learn how to organize
your code properly the other thing about
tailwind is that it doesn't provide
pre-built components for you so you
still need to do a lot of work on your
own there are other popular css
frameworks out there like bootstrap or
bulma what makes it different than
tailwind is that it provides pre-built
components giving you a solid collection
of styles for things like buttons cards
and so on to use it in next.js all you
have to do is install it with npm then
import the bootstrap stylesheet from
your node modules it doesn't have the
tooling that tailwind does but to use it
all you have to do is start referencing
the classes in your components it's
simple effective and has a minimal
learning curve however if you're only
using the bootstrap style sheet you
might find yourself creating your own
components to wrap those styles in a way
that can be efficiently used with other
components like you might have a
bootstrap button component to avoid
repeating the same class names over and
over again another problem is that using
bootstrap like this will result in a
large bundle size because there are a
lot of unused classes that will get
included in the final css when it comes
to react a more tightly integrated
approach is to use a full-blown
component library there are ones that
already do that for bootstrap but the
react ecosystem has many other design
systems that you'll want to check out an
awesome one i've been using lately is
manteen not only does it handle much of
your css but it provides a ton of
utilities to handle things that you
would otherwise have to do in javascript
as well like hooks to use the
intersection observer api to know when
an element is visible it also has tools
to manage modals and notifications
calendars and a ton of other stuff now
libraries like this tend to be fairly
opinionated so make sure to choose one
that you really like other ones worth
checking out are ant material design
rebase chakra and tamagui that's not a
complete list so let me know your
favorite library in the comments
congratulations you now know seven
different ways to deal with css and
react keep in mind that you can mix and
match all these different techniques to
use whatever works best for your
application if you want to learn more
advanced concepts with full project
courses become a pro member at fireship
io thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next one